the u.s government claims these are
not detention centers but photos taken
from inside
u.s border patrol facilities have
stirred an outcry
thousands of teenagers and younger
children crowded into pens and sleeping
on floors
held in these conditions for more than
five days
in violation of a court order requiring
they be moved to more
child friendly shelters within 72 hours
those detention centers are jails i mean
they are
they are guarded by agents and officers
the u.s homeland security secretary and
a contingent of senators
toured a border patrol facility holding
children friday
media were barred from entering
officials said
due to covet concerns we are
safely processing the children who do
come to our border
we strongly urge and the message is
clear
not to do so now under the trump
administration
thousands of migrant children who
arrived at the u.s border had been
expelled to mexico without seeing an
immigration judge
president joe biden ended the practice
calling it inhumane
now immigration officials report more
than 9 000
unaccompanied children entering the u.s
in february
and since then it's been an average of
500
more a day children
presenting at our border who are fleeing
violence
who are fleeing prosecution who are
fleeing terrible situations
is not a crisis in an effort to expedite
moving the miners to better conditions
the biden administration has deployed
fema the government agency that handles
disasters
to turn the dallas convention center
into an emergency shelter
for 2 000 children three other temporary
shelters are in operation
or being planned there migrant children
wait
another 30-some days but with access to
school
and recreation until the government
places them with a u.s
sponsor that process of waiting for
sponsorship
should be shortened and now we need to
put more resources there
but also while they wait they should be
put in place
and in care of non-profits and
faith-based organizations and
but by no means border patrol is the
alternative for these children
the white house says it's sending
messages to central american countries
for their youth
not to come that includes seventeen
thousand
ads on the radio social media and
television
it's unclear how many children are
listening in their home countries
what's obvious is that their numbers at
the u.s border
continue to grow heidi joe castro al
jazeera
washington